we all know the famous artists whose
work sells for Millions Dali Warhol
hockney Picasso Coons they're all men
Now new researchers found that despite
leaps in gender equality since the days
of the Old Masters contemporary art by
men sells for significantly more than
work by women
I don't think there's any excuse for
there to be a difference in anything to
do with the Arts I mean if you're
looking at something it doesn't matter
who it was made by if you love if you
love what you see then the value that it
has should be the value that it is no
matter what gender you know it has been
created by
but new data suggests the gender of an
artist is more important than the art
itself
for every one pound fetched by a male
artist's work that of a woman gets just
10p but even worse than that the value
of a painting increases when a man signs
it but decreases when it's a woman's
name on the canvas
the woman who did the research says
finding the industry is still so gender
biased is a blow to women preparing to
launch their careers in fact there have
been quite prominent artists who have
about to be going into some collections
some big collections across the world
and they were told when they found out
they were actually women that they
wouldn't accept them in the collections
industry experts say there's a demand
for women's work it's just one the
marketplace isn't satisfying
seventy percent of our artist roster are
female artists and their work is hugely
in demand so the demand is there for
their work aesthetically when it's
curated into collections but we're not
seeing that return when it comes to
auction or secondary Market Marketplace
misogyny or unconscious collusion
whichever way you look at it while
Beauty might be in the eye of the
beholder value in the art world seems
set firmly by the gender of the Creator
Bethany mannell Sky News